et
avant gardiste précurseur qu'est ce qui
nous définit vraiment dans la vie c'est
ce que l'on fait ou c'est ce que l'on
est
certains se posent la question le matin
mais qui suis-je qui suis-je
qu'est ce que je suis où j'en suis
cette question est posée depuis 1601 par
un certain william shakespeare dans sa
pièce hamlet
c'est une acte 3 to be or not to be
d'aller se coucher
et depuis toutes ces années à chaque
fois et pour toute l'humanité
et même pour moi même je me pose la
question qui suis-je coup haye m alors
je voudrais qu'on arrête de souffrir un
tout petit peu qu'on se lâche de cette
citation être ne pas être pour
s'intéresser à une situation faire ou ne
pas être
parce que si on ne fait rien c'est sûr
on ne sera rien
si on s'implique pas si on ne s'investit
pas si on se donne pas corps et âme on
ne sera pas celui qu'on rêverait d'être
il faut se poser la question du fair
lettres suivre quand vous étiez petits
pots temps les parents nous ont donné
cette chance
nos éducateurs ils ont certainement
poser cette question qu'est ce que tu
aimerais faire quand tu seras grand
posez vous cette question qu'est ce que
tu aimerais faire quand tu seras plus
grands ce matin je me baladais et j'ai
voulu poser cette question pour voir si
on répondait toujours de la même manière
avec ces jeunes qui étaient là dans la
rue et jeudi mais petit plus grand qu
est ce que tu aimerais faire il m'a
répondu systématiquement j'aimerais être
président de la république le rêver
possible
ils ont répondu j'aimerais être ministre
député j'aimerais être pilote et je me
dis on n'arrive pas à répondre à cette
question qu'est ce que tu aimerais faire
quand tu seras plus grave et je me suis
encore posé la question là à des cousins
jeudi nombre et on m'a répondu
j'aimerais être riche j'aimerais être
célèbre mais sans pouvoir dire ce que je
voulais faire et moi dans mon métier
c'est danny messer de faire des
événements mettre en lumière des
personnes
c'est ce que je fais c'est ce que j'aime
faire et quand je le fais les gens
viennent nous voir mais comment tu
arrives à faire tout simplement comment
tu arrivé à faire ces choses là c'est
évident comme tu fais ça et je vais vous
révéler le tout premier secret et
j'aimerais qu'on puisse y est vous
concentrer quand on pose cette question
comment tu fais premier secret je
commence
salesses
premier ce fait comment tu fais je
commence on dit oui mais quand tu fais
tu peux tomber tu peux harris ne tue pas
rares échecs
deuxième secret j'ai dû me je commence
il doute autant que je douce
il est vrai qu'on puisse s'arrêter là
mais on n'en a pas mais je ne m'arrête
jamais jamais ça et je commence je
recommence et je ne m'arrête jamais
c'est aussi simple que ça je ne pose pas
de questions tout ça parce que oui je
suis costaud menti et cetera mais je
m'intéresse pas ça je me connais ce fait
à faire des choses intéressantes tout à
l'heure quand on m'a présenté j'eus eu
cette chance d'habiter dans plusieurs
villes du pays
moscou tunisie par ligne france toulouse
montréal et deux par le travail des
parents des diplomates
je ne savais que je pouvais rester
présent que 4,50 tour bus et dans
l'index aussi l'outil comme vous je ne
prenais pas à cette question qu'est ce
que j'aimerais faire comme les grands
jurys commerce
ravi de faire de créer de faire exister
parce que le palais
j'avais envie de créer des équipes javel
je regardais quand les clips vidéo
j'avais envie d'être un chanteur
et puis je vais faire quelque chose et
j'ai cherché des anneaux qui tu es
passionné par sa cuisine parce que ces
passionnés d'art culture et la lumière a
remis un merci à vous et moi pour la
belle tenue des volumes vendus et
j'étais fasciné l'emploi anem culture et
justement je voulais chanter mais
parfois il faut pouvoir arriver à
chanter se devait de répondre et je suis
si je ne peux pas le faire tout ce que
je fais avec des amis chanté beaucoup
mieux que moi et là ça nous voir
l'elysée
à se prendre pour les boks mais agit de
nos voix et le séduire satisfaits et ont
chanté dans les collèges avec la cage et
dans la salle des jeunes que nous
regarder et ils ont eu envie aussi
nous allons nous faire aujourd'hui ils
ont dans les tournées internationales
je suis vraiment contente cette couleur
toxiques et champion dès 9 heures ils
sont dans le monde entier afin de
partager une source
et c'est parce que j'avais envie de
faire ces choses là je me sens tout les
cas c'est une autre situation
quand je chantais les armes sur cet
arrêté j'ai envie de continuer et
arrivant à montréal
après la france j'ai adressé au
gouvernement culturel de cette nuit là
comment je vais arriver à faire cette
chose là bas j'ai commencé un projet
avec un ami que j'avais rencontré à
toulouse qui faisait aussi de la musique
et avec qui j'avais beaucoup de plaisir
qui était très talentueux dans ce
domaine était plutôt hip hop on était
plutôt le côté son ennemi vous savez
petit côté un peu lover de la chose on
s'est dit mais on a déjà fait tout ça on
prépare le refaire ici
mais les festivals était tellement
important qu'on a dit commencer à faire
quelque chose dans une toute petite
salle on a commencé à faire un concept
événement qui a fonctionné les gens
venaient les uns après les autres
certains artistes confirmés venez des
gens qui n'osaient même pas chanter ont
commencé à chanter
aujourd'hui quand je regarde en arrière
six à sept ans plus tard l'une de ces
dames la gr un festival depuis le canada
dans toute l'afrique
on a commencé par faire et ça susciter
quelque chose chez quelqu'un d'autre à
la même époque à montréal j'étais ainsi
tranquillement avec mon épouse et
regarder la télévision et ont été
percutées frappé bouleversé choqué par
des images de mon pays que je voyais et
j'aimais qu'est-ce que je peux faire
qu'est ce que j'aime faire qu'est ce que
j'ai déjà fait qui pourrait m'aider à
changer ce que je n'aime pas ce que je
ne vois pas il y avait un petit concept
comme ça parti de rien et un des
organisateurs est venu me trouver en
disant écoute je vois ce que tu fais et
j'aime la façon dont tu le fais il ne
savait pas qui j'étais
la question n'est pas de savoir qui on
est mais ce que l'on fait il a dit est
ce que tu aimerais être embarqué dans ce
projet qui s'appelle le dîner en blanc
je te vois bien comme directeur
artistique avec tha
ta fille parce que tu apportes écoute ça
c'est fou c'est un événement tu vas pas
connaître le lieu les gens vont arriver
à bien blancs ils vont monter dans des
bus ils vont payer pour se retrouver là
ils vont apporter leur propre technique
leur propre nourriture leurs propres
boissons ils vont s'installer dans les
endroits qu'on leur a dit et ils vont
dîner pendant un temps limité
ils ont tout nettoyé ils vont partir je
dis ouah mais blanc il s'en va et on a
vécu cette aventure là on a continué
pendant trois années et lorsqu'on a
lancé sa de new york a commencé à avoir
ça aux états unis zone i just go ce qui
ouvrirait bon je veux la même chose et
new york a commencé à le faire première
édition plus de 30000 personnes
voulaient participer à cette édition
et quand j'ai dit à mon très cher
aymeric amis j'ai dit mais tu sais quoi
le pays est bizarre en ce moment
j'aimerais faire ça en afrique en
afrique avec tout ce qu'il ya dans vos
têtes
et j'ai dit oui j'aimerais le faire en
afrique alors j'ai commencé justement
dans mon travail j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer un designer qui s'appelait
alphadi qui fait un festival dans le
dans le désert pour ceux qui le
connaissent il était venu présenter une
de ses collections à montréal et là
j'avais fait et réaliser son animation
et m'a dit mais pourquoi tu viendrais
pas on était en 2011 je crois faire et
présentait donc mon festival de défilés
de mode dans le désert jeudi mais c'est
complètement fou ça organiser un
festival de mode dans le désert pourquoi
pas bingo j'y vais je prépare tout je
m'imagine la chose et c est là je
commence à donner envie à cette histoire
de dinan blanc d'exister quelque part en
afrique et bien sûr à abidjan là je
commence à sonder j'appelle les gens ça
réagit pas on dit mais à abidjan ici des
choses que tu fais là bas tu veut les
emmener ici demander aux gens de laisser
leur voiture
insécurité monter dans des bus je ne dis
pas où est ce qu'ils vont aller je leur
demandais de ne pas se faire servir mais
de prendre leur nourriture mettre ça
dans une glacière de prendre leurs
bagages de ne pas s'habiller comme ils
veulent
le sablier stictement en blanc et rien
qu'en
et en plus de ça je vais leur demander
de payer pour venir s'installer dans une
table qui vont installer et à la fin je
leur demandais de tout nettoyer avant de
partir merci on m'a dit petit bien si
j'ai dit ça ça fonctionne pas comme ça
ici on ne fait pas ça tu ne connais pas
assez de gens mais d'ailleurs qui tu es
pour faire ces choses là tu sais nous on
a des habitudes nos cultures et tout ça
ça va pas marcher son affaire il ya un
autre élément lorsque vous voulez faire
quelque chose et que vous devez
commencer recommencer ne jamais vous
arrêtez la toute première chose que vous
pouvez commencer à faire c'est d'en
parler et c'est ce que j'ai voulu faire
et quand j'ai voulu dire mais je vais en
parler on a dit et on en afrique ici ne
dit pas des choses fait ça doucement si
je peux pas dire mon idée ce n'est pas
la partager je me suis dit ok peut-être
que c'est la façon avec laquelle je pose
la question et je me suis dit je vais
pas leur dire mon idée ou parlé de mon
idée mais je veux redire
qu'est-ce qui penseraient par exemple de
voir un restaurant au milieu d'une yagg
d'une lagune et là vous transférez votre
démarche
ce n'est plus j'ai envie de faire ça
qu'est ce que tu en penses tu penses que
ça va marcher
ce la réponse ça là ça ne marchera
jamais et je transfère la demande
la question qu'est ce que tu penserais
de et jeux de transfert ça chez lui et
lui va m'alimenter il va me donner les
éléments de peur qu'ils m'auraient donné
si j'ai posé ma question
j'ai moi envie qui suit nos balais ici
de faire tout ça il murray bloqué stoppe
net
alors pour commencer il faut déjà
commencer à en parler mais savoir
comment parler de ce projet là c'est
très important parce que lorsqu'on la
porte
ça peut être la peur de l'autre qui
régirait j'aille sur vous lorsque vous
l'emmenez l'heure le projet le plus fou
le plus débile possible les gens vous
arrêtant des en redescend sur terre on
ne fait pas ça ici
quelle est l'essence même c'est de faire
des choses ou d'être parce que plus on
va faire et lorsqu'on se cherche tout le
temps en temps en train de se dire mais
qui suis-je on n'a jamais cette réponse
jusqu'à la fin de notre vie
mais ce qu'on a comme élément c'est tout
ce qu'on a fait qui deviendra notre
définition de ce que l'on est
alors il faut commencer par faire
quelque chose ne pas hésiter échoué oui
c'est obligatoire d'échouer parce que
c'est en échouant que vous puissiez vous
pouvez arriver à retransformer ce que
vous avez tenté de faire faites ce que
vous aimez faire le plus mettez de la
passion dans ce que vous faites
j'ai eu la chance de faire ce métier
mais c'est ma femme est un jour qui m'a
dit lorsqu'elle me voyait faire mais
fair for no he is sur scène mais ce que
tu sais que c'est un vrai métier ce truc
là
comment ça c'est un vrai métier oui on
gagne de l'argent
oui on fait bouger des choses oui tu
peux prendre cette responsabilité et m'a
inspiré est motivée alors qu'elle même
elle est terrifiée lorsque monte sur
scène mais dit vas-y chérie tu peux le
faire mais ce métier là et j'ai pris ma
passion mon intérêt mon amour ce qui
faisait vibrer pour le transformer dans
un métier mais ce n'est pas un métier
que je voulais faire parce que c'est
encore répondre à cette question qu'est
ce que tu aimerais faire quand tu seras
grand
j'aimerais être c'est pas le métier
c'était pas la fonction c'était le
mouvement que je voulais créer
c'étaient les lignes que je voulais
faire bouger et particulièrement ici sur
ce continent
on a besoin de faire et de refaire et ne
jamais s'arrêter
souvent lorsque les gens viennent ici 10
mai regardez cette terre d'opportunités
et nous hésitons pourquoi on ne sait pas
comment démarrer mais commencer ça
démarrera après parce que quand j'ai
commencé cette aventure avec des amis d
associer avec mon épouse qui est rentré
dans le projet on a commencé on était
trois cent cinquante tout au plus et les
gens m'avaient dit non c'est pas
possible ça va pas fonctionner et cetera
et cetera etc et on est parti tout
doucement première année 300 jusqu'à six
ans plus tard à plus de 2000
participants des gens qui venaient
spécialement du ghana pour vivre cette
édition là les personnes qui ont quitté
le texas aux états unis pour être
présents à cette édition et jean qui
était à paris à singapour
des gens qui étaient en angola du côté
de kigali est justement un petit clin
d'oeil à kigali qui était et deux
premières villes avec abidjan avoir
lancé ce ce projet sous licence et
c'était ce qu'on cherche à faire créer
du mouvement générer quelque chose
quelque chose qui était beaucoup plus
grand que notre simple personne notre
simple être il fallait faire plus fort
plus grands faire et refaire ça justin
ne pas lâcher et parfois lorsque vous
faites il ya des rendez vous de la vie
qui vous perturbe et vous donne toutes
les raisons de vous arrêter de se dire
j'ai pas pu faire tu peux comprendre
juste pour savoir si j'ai du temps on
était deux trois années à président de
l'andrh et cette même année j'avais
réalisé un beau projet avec mon père
c'était justement de faire de la côte
d'ivoire le pays vedette dans un forum
économique au canada et on a commencé
très tôt donc le forum était au mois de
septembre au mois de janvier on a
commencé à rédiger des lettres très
officiel envoyé le tout et j'ai demandé
à mon père donc de faire les démarches
et pouvoir s'ils pouvaient approcher
certaines personnes pour voir faire de
la côte d'ivoire le pays vedette dans ce
forum là et mon père a dû aller monter
les escaliers des différents tours parce
que les dossiers souvent lorsque vous
les envoyez commence à descendre en bas
de la pile et en a dicté sa dette est
impossible ou difficile on a provoqué
les choses on a bousculé
j'ai fait le déplacement et dans cette
aventure là on devait en même temps
livré le 10 novembre
ici à abidjan et mon père est tombé
malade au même moment très rapidement de
trois années de trois mois pardon
détecter un cancer on est au mois
d'avril mars à mars avril mai le temps
avance la maladie se prononce le dîner
en blanc se profile ce forum économique
va finalement confirmé la côte d'ivoire
comme pays vedettes et en même temps
cette même année de bonheur 2013 chez ma
toute première fille et on arrive là on
arrive à réaliser ce forum économique
avec la cua du vin comme pays vedette et
on annonce que finalement ça va être
très très grave mon père s'est quasiment
cuit comme on dit et à ce même moment on
est dans la quinzaine d'octobre
le 19 on est en train de fêter
l'anniversaire de mariage de mon nez
vous le 22 mai toute première fille
venait au monde le 23 mon père
disparaissait le 25 octobre de célébrer
mon anniversaire et quelques semaines
après je devais réaliser ce dîner en
blanc ici à abidjan alors que j'étais au
canada ça demandait de quitter le canada
venir enterrer mon père est réalisée cet
événement là on me dit mais comment tu
as fait je sais pas j'ai commencé par
faire et je devais m'arrêter
on m'a dit non culturellement c'est pas
bon ça se fait pas et j'ai dit non je
vais le faire parce que je sais ce que
ça représente de crise émouvant sacré
autre chose sacrée quelque chose de
beaucoup plus grand que nous eh oui
c'est possible il faut commencer
recommencez faire sans cesse et sans
cesse sans s'arrêter
j'espère que vous avez vous aussi nous
aider à créer ce mouvement et être
générateur de mouvement une phrase et je
terminerai avec sa d'un certain twain et
je crois si je me trompe pas qui disait
il ne savait pas que c'était impossible
donc ils l'ont fait
[Musique]